when you plan on shooting it what do you
think you'll do differently what are
some things that you know that you know
I learned from this whether it was
location that fell through we're gonna
hire more people I mean ideally
depending on the budget I've said any
more people yeah big crew more people in
pre-production helping and in
post-production so definitely more
people that's really about it I mean
just more people with the bigger the
team the bigger army you have the easier
it is for you as a producer on the film
so you you know you're not juggling too
many hats you have other people helping
out socially just hanging more people
and delegating these duties and jobs to
these other people do you like to do a
lot of stuff yourself you know there's
certain people that they don't have to
just be really hands-on I do I do um
like I do a lot of editing on this last
one that meets an editor my under me
writing it but I didn't do a lot of
editing on it and um that was very
tedious I did a lot of stuff like the
trailers and some little things but like
you know promotional stuff but I think
um editing is it's that's the poor I
don't say I hate the most but it's very
tedious and time-consuming out of all
the things and that's why I told my team
I was like hey this next one there's no
way I'm not whole elated many of the
beginnings may help out the trailers
obviously let's move and I'll give him
the notes on how I kind of want it I'm
like this last one I was doing like 30
meters my purse in that scene validating
myself and I didn't like the other 3035
percent I was kind of telling matter
what what I wanted and stuff and I let
him end it like that 35 percent to say
just edit and it was a lot of like
dialogue and stuff because it was some
complex scenes in there what we're like
stabbing scene or like a torture scene
or a shooting scene or something like
that where it had to be done and edited
a certain way a certain weight I had in
mind what I thought just because of the
shot list but I came out with my
photographer that's just from studying
films for so long it's hard to explain
to somebody like hey when someone gets
stabbed for this the camera and use the
flip to this angle
so over here to show this is the
reaction of this actors face hi you know
the 94 whatever it is I said explain
that that's Chi user just do it because
you've seen it in films and how you want
it with the shower she came out with so
that was it was a lot of hands-on with
that but this next one night I don't
want it's to time because I just I live
someone just do it and all correct notes
or anything whatever what are you using
to edit on I do premiere ok it's a good
program awful yeah I minor had a big pc
i know lucky wait off max but he had a
huge pc station that's what we added on
it so i was doing that adobe and you
taught yourself how to use the Adobe
Creative Suite actually while in that my
filmmaking course classes and we start
at an island OB from all the things I
shot we learned at the computers in the
lab how to edit off of there from the
professor out to Pickering's a great
professor from USC and he teaches the
course in East LA he um yeah he was
teaching you know how to edit and stuff
and we just learn from like the courses
and the materials and the guides they
had like like these little C roms like
guys and I kind of walking through stuff
and that's fine learned and just went
from there
you